allez, c'est
l'homme qui a été pour un
acteur fantastique et le cinéma, s'il vous plaît, bienvenue au producteur
et et
[Applaudissements]
Angelina,
il est l'
homme d'un acteur fantastique au cinéma,
veuillez accueillir le producteur et la star
de et
[Applaudissements]
Angelina
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre
s'il vous
plaît [Applaudissements] s'il vous plaît [Applaudissements] [
Musique]
retournez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] s'il vous plaît, dites à
gauche, à gauche, à gauche, s'il vous plaît,
rejoignez-
nous pour
jouer le lieutenant israélien San dans World
War Z,
s'il vous plaît, accueillez Daniela
[Applaudissements]
curz
et maintenant nous étions ensemble en train de nous
battre à l'extérieur et grâce à
vous